Earth was destroyed and humans were
forced to leave but after a few years
the survivors decided to take another
chance and revive their home but the
planet has totally changed already it's
been 97 years since a nuclear apocalypse
killed almost everyone on Earth the
planet was simmering with radiation and
the only survivors were those who had
operational space stations they forged
and created a new home in space called
The Ark the residents of Ark are told
that Earth will become inhabitable once
again soon but it's just a dream the
reality is really harsh the population
of Ark is increasing rapidly and they
don't have enough resources that's why
the authorities are always looking for
an excuse to kill people even for the
smallest crime the guilty gets executed
mercilessly one of the unfortunate
criminals is Clark Griffin she also
dreams of going to Earth but she will be
executed as soon as she turns 18 there's
4 months left till her next birthday but
the jailers come for her all of a sudden
Clark assumes that she is going to be
killed but her mother Abby informs her
about about the journey to Earth all the
100 prisoners under custody will take
part in an experiment in which they will
be sent to Earth to check its current
state after getting in the spaceship
Clark finds Chancellor's son Wells jaha
he really cares about her and he
willingly got himself arrested so he can
take care of Clark but she hates him
because her father was executed by the
chancellor her mother is still alive
only because she is a medical expert
before departing the passengers receive
a video message from the chancellor
tonius jaha he warns them that they have
no idea what's waiting down there on
Earth that's why they have chosen to
send the criminals and if they survive
their crimes will be forgiven the drop
site for the spaceship is chosen very
carefully it will land on Mountain
weather where there used to be a
military camp that has enough resources
to sustain 300 people the only task the
prisoners need to carry out is to stay
alive they must keep their wristbands on
as they will provide the ark with their
health details the spaceship has
departed but two of the rebellious boys
take off off their seat belts as soon as
the spaceship enters the Earth's
atmosphere it falls down brutally and
hits the ground the boys who took off
their seat belts have died from the
impact but they are still 100 because
two siblings Octavia and Bellamy sneaked
in the ship Bellamy opens the door and
surprisingly the Earth seems to have
recovered the air is breathable and
there are trees all around they have
landed on the wrong site and lost
communication with the ark but the
wristbands are still working so the
authorities know about the hundred ziz
health conditions and deaths Clark
suggests that they should head to the
weather Mountain but not all of them
agree Wells is injured so Clark leaves
with Octavia and three other boys named
Finn Monty and Jasper Finn seems to be
interested in Clark and is ready to
fully support her on this mission on
their way they find several unique
plants and an animal but they have
abnormalities due to the nuclear
radiations Octavia spots a river and
recklessly jumps in to have a bath but
soon gets attacked by a mysterious
creature luckily Jasper risks his life
to to save her and earns her favor they
get more careful on their way ahead and
avoid interacting with animals back near
the spaceship the other passengers are
still doubtful of the authorities they
believe that if they survive the others
will also fly down and put them again in
jail that's why several prisoners
destroy their wristbands so the
authorities will assume that they have
died Wells tries to stop them but they
don't listen and plan to kill him
because of the harsh laws his father
made but instead they forcely take off
his wristband so the chancellor will
assume that his son has died meanwhile
on the ark the chancellor is found
injured he has been shot and lost a lot
of blood the person under suspension is
Bellamy but he has already escaped to
Earth he Avenged his mother who was
executed for hiding her daughter because
no one is allowed to have a second child
to save the chancellor Abby provides an
illegal amount of blood to him the
merciless councilman Cain finds this out
and orders aby's execution he just wants
to find a chance to decrease the
population on the ark fortunately the
chancellor wakes Wes up and saves Abby
in time the next morning Clark and her
team try using tree branches to cross
the river Jasper goes first to impress
Octavia with his bravery after reaching
the other side he starts to celebrate
his success but the next moment he gets
attacked by a spear they are not alone
on this planet others start running away
to save themselves but Clark hears
Jasper's screams and turns back to save
him unfortunately he is already taken
away by someone they all return to the
camp and stop the fight between and
Bellamy afterward they tell everyone
that there are some survivors on Earth
which they called the grounders Clark
sees the missing wristbands and scolds
everyone for being too Reckless the ark
is dying and they are the only hope to
save Humanity but Bellamy thinks the
opposite he wants to cut all
communication with the ark and start a
new life on Earth Clark can't fight him
as he has a lot of people on his side
she gives up and decides to rescue
Jasper Wells and Monty want to help her
but he only allows Wells because Monty
has lots of knowledge about tech and
plants they can't risk losing him Clark
requests Bellamy to join as he has a gun
Bellamy agrees because he wants to get a
chance to take off her wristband but
when he tries to do that Finn gets in
the way he joins them as well to protect
Clark after walking for a while they
take a bath in the river and get to the
other side there they found some fresh
spots of blood Jasper has passed from
here after walking further Clark finds
Jasper tied up on a tree as she steps
forward she almost Falls in a pit it was
a bit set up by the grounders they had
treated Jasper's wounds so he could be
used to attract his mates luckily none
of them fell in the Trap but a dangerous
animal attacks them out of nowhere Wells
immediately takes out the gun and shoots
the animal to death back at the camp
Bellamy left his friend Adam to take
care of Octavia but he falls for her
charms himself and starts a romantic
relationship with her meanwhile on the
ark Abby is still trying to communicate
with the 100s the chancellor also comes
to check on on the progress but he gets
depressed on seeing that Wells may have
died as well Abby tries to calm him down
and explains that they are not sure what
the wristbands are indicating it may be
a glitch as it's difficult to accept
that 24 kids have already died she helps
theonas in treating his wounds and asks
him to rest he has a lot to take care of
after she leaves Cain comes to check on
the chancellor he tells him about
Bellamy but Theus suspects that Cain is
involved in attacking him because after
thonus dies Cain will become the next
champ cellor but Cain refuses to accept
that and also mocks the lonus for being
too weak to take the right decisions
under the current circumstances once the
chancellor gets a little better an
emergency meeting is called to decide
their next strategy the public will soon
find out about the shortage of resources
and they will create chaos while
preparing for the meeting Abby struggles
to figure out why the kids are dying
suddenly a young mechanic named Raven
comes there and deduces that the kids
may be taking off the wristbands Abby
says the same thing thing in the meeting
and asks for more time to prove that
Earth has recovered Cain doesn't accept
that as they are running out of time
they are only left with 4 months worth
of oxygen and need 6 months to engineer
more resources if they don't kill 200
more people from the ark they may have
to kill even more after 4 months half of
the board is with Cain but Thelonius
refuses to vote and according to the law
the decision is delayed for another 10
days Abby must figure out something
within these days she takes Raven to a
secret laboratory and requests her to
build a spaceship that can carry at
least 320 people if Cain wins and orders
to kill those people Abby will send them
to Earth
instead back on Earth Jasper is taken to
the camp and treated further Bellamy
finds out about octavia's relationship
with Adam and hangs Adam on a tree for
the whole night so he never dares again
to get near Octavia Finn has also
brought the animal they killed so they
cook it for dinner finally they have a
proper meal after two whole days but
their happiness is not for long as the
grounders have found their camp Jasper
is alive but the infection in his wounds
is getting worse he screams continuously
in pain and the others are already fed
up with him except for his friends Clark
advises Jasper not to lose hope she goes
to bring some water for him but on the
way she runs into the youngest member
charlot she has been suffering from
nightmares since her parents were
executed Clark Comforts her and tells
her that it's time to move on to start a
new life on Earth the next morning
brings another disaster a huge wave of
acidic smoke is circulating in the
forest it has already killed two people
their disappearance is scaring others
Bellamy doesn't want anyone to think of
contacting the ark so he decides to
cheer them up with some food he takes
Adam and his other friend Jones and they
go hunting on the way they find
Charlotte who is having trouble
adjusting to this new lifestyle Bellamy
advises her to be brave and gives her a
knife so she can join them in hunting
they spot a boar and Rush after it but
the smoke wave proceeds towards them
Bellamy takes Charlotte and they hide in
the cave while Jones and Adam are left
behind mean meanwhile Clark is
researching the medicine which the
grounders applied on Jasper's wounds
Wells recognizes it as seaweed and Finn
knows where to find it all three of them
head to the river and collect some
seaweed they also encounter the smoke
wave but hide in an automobile they
found in the forest Finn looks around
and comes across a bottle of wine he
shares it with Clark which makes her a
little dizzy Wells asks her if they can
be friends again but Clark says she can
never forgive him she still remembered
what happened one year ago Clark and
Wells were best friend friends and they
used to spend most of the time together
Clark's father was researching the ark's
oxygen resource and learned that it's
going to run out soon he wanted to
inform the public as it's their right
but Abby stopped him because it can
cause Panic Clark heard this
conversation and shared it with Wells
after a few days her father decided to
record a video and illegally share it on
the announcement Channel but before he
could do that the police arrived and
took him for execution clarky blamed
Wells for telling this secret to the
chancellor and broke their friend
friendship forever as the smoke subsides
they get out of the automobile and
proceed towards the camp they run into
Bellamy Jones and Charlotte they all are
fine but Adam is burned by the acidic
smoke he can't bear the pain anymore and
asks his friends to kill him Clark takes
the knife and pierces it through Adam's
neck so he doesn't have to deal with a
slow painful death afterwards they take
the dead body back to the camp which
breaks octavia's heart some of the
campers try killing Jasper to get rid of
the screaming but Octavia can't let
anyone kill another of her loved ones
she keeps sitting beside Jasper and
Clark gives him the medicine she made
with the seaweed by the next morning
Jasper gets really better after getting
a chance Finn asks Clark how she is so
sure that Wells told the chancellor
about his father she finally starts
thinking over it deeply and confronts
Wells she asks him to tell the truth but
Wells stays quiet Clara has realized
that it was actually her mother who told
the authorities Wells never tried to
defend himself because he thought the
truth would hurt Clark he kept getting
hated by Clark just to protect her Clark
feels really guilty and asks for
forgiveness Wells hugs her and says this
is what friends are for after such a
long time he earned back Clark's
friendship but Fate has stored something
else for him later that night Charlotte
comes to talk to Wells as she can't fall
asleep she tells Wells that she has
found a cure to her nightmares saying
this she kills wells in the same way as
Clark killed Jasper Charlotte confesses
that she keeps seeing dreams of her
parents getting killed by the chancellor
when she wakes up she sees Wells and
suffers again therefore she killed him
so she is not reminded of the tragic
event anymore this is only the start of
the 100's life on Earth more challenges
are waiting for them and more secrets to
unfold the only goal is to stay alive
but it isn't that easy